could you give advice to young people
today in high school or college they're
trying to pave
their life story whether it's in science
or elsewhere how they can have a career
they can be proud of or a life they can
be proud of advice boy it's dangerous to
give advice because things change so
fast but uh one Central thing I can say
moving up and through Academia and
whatnot you will be surrounded by really
smart people and what you need to do is
be very careful at distinguishing
specific
critique versus kind of Meta Meta advice
and what I mean by that is
if if somebody really smart and
successful and obviously uh competent is
giving you specific
um critiques on what you've done it
that's gold that's an opportunity to
hone your craft to get better at what
you're doing to learn to find your
mistakes like that's great
if they are telling you what you ought
to be studying how you ought to approach
things what is the right way to think
about things
you should probably ignore most of that
and the reason I make that distinction
is that a lot of really
um a really successful uh people are
very well calibrated on their own ideas
and they on in their own field and their
own you know sort of uh area and they
know exactly what works and what doesn't
and what's good and what's bad but
they're not calibrated on your ideas and
so so uh the things they will they will
say oh you know this is a dumb idea
don't do this and you shouldn't do that
that stuff is generally uh worse than
worse than useless it can be very very
um uh demoralizing and and and and
really limiting and so so what I say to
people is read very broadly work really
hard know what you're talking about take
all specific criticism as a
um as an opportunity to improve what
you're doing and then completely ignore
everything else because I I just tell
you from like from from my own
experience um most of what I consider to
be interesting and useful things that
we've done very smart people have said
this is a terrible idea don't don't
don't do that don't you know just um
yeah I think I think we we just don't
know we have no idea beyond beyond our
own like at best we know what we ought
to be doing we very rarely know what
anybody else should be doing yeah and
their ideas
their perspective has been also
calibrated not just on their field and
specific situation but also on a state
of that field at a particular time in
the past so there's not many people in
this world that are able to achieve
revolutionary success multiple times in
their life so whenever you say somebody
very smart usually what that means is
somebody who's smart who achieved the
success at certain point in their life
and people often get stuck in that place
where they found success to be
constantly challenging your world view
is a very difficult thing
um so yeah and that also at the same
time probably if a lot of people tell
that's the weird thing about life if a
lot of people tell you
that something is stupid or is not going
to work
that either means it's stupid it's not
going to work or
it's actually a great opportunity to do
something new
and you don't know which one it is it's
probably equally likely to be either if
no well I don't know the probabilities
depends how lucky you are it depends how
brilliant you are but you don't know and
so you can't take that advice as actual
data yeah you have to um you have to and
this is this is kind of hard and fuzzy
like hard to describe and fuzzy but I
I'm uh a firm believer that you have to
uh build up your own intuition so over
time right you have to take your own
risks that seem like they make sense to
you and then learn from that and build
up so that you can trust your own gut
about what's a good idea even when and
then sometimes you'll make mistakes and
it'll turn out to be a dead end and
that's fine that's that's science but
but um you know what I tell my students
is is uh life is hard and science is is
hard and you're going to sweat and bleed
and everything and you should be doing
that for uh ideas that that really fire
you up inside and and um you know and
and really don't let uh kind of the uh
the a common denominator of
standardized approaches to things slow
you down